it's four in the morning and the camp is
awake they're starting to break down
tents and pack whatever they can carry
it's his last techus a sort of base camp
for migrants attempting to cross from
Colombia to Panama they're from all over
the world desperate enough to take on a
journey that was once considered nigh on
Impossible
now though it's full of families many
are babies
this little one has been bitten by
insects she's covered in bites they
haven't got to the Jungle yet well it's
absolutely pitched back still on the
camp has been up for absolutely hours I
don't think there's any chance of
daylight for at least another hour all
the tents are being packed up people are
looking for food they're getting their
supplies and Provisions ready I think
the sort of air of trepidation but also
sort of excitement that they're getting
on the way on what can be an incredibly
arduous trip but they all seem to be you
know this is the day they've been
waiting for the start
of their Journey Through the Darion Gap
first light they gathered to take
instructions this is a massive organized
smuggling operation
Smugglers traveled with the group to
show them the way
the gate opens and they flood through
them is a 65-mile Journey Through Rivers
jungle and over mountains
it'll take five days at best
they crisscross the River on the valley
floor heading for the higher ground
dozens of times
the sheer numbers of families and the
numbers of tiny children attempting this
is astonishing
everyone helps slipping on rocks beneath
the water little ones grab their parents
parents grab their children hoisting
them onto their backs but everyone keeps
moving
Michael is from Venezuela his wife Mary
Angela is seven months pregnant their
two boys are four and two they've
actually come from Chile and they've
been walking for months already
like everyone America is their goal
s
150 000 people attempted this Trek in
the first nine months of this year a
decade ago barely 200 attempted it
don't be afraid of sign reads they're
all along the Route
urging the migrant song
the jungle is full of deadly snakes
spiders and insects it's scorching hot
and humid
[Music]
very quickly the migrant groups thin out
the youngest and fittest leave the
weaker ones behind
[Music]
this lady has sprained her ankle already
it's impossible to imagine that she will
actually make it but she keeps going
simple stairs have been cut into muddy
Hills without them it would take hours
to cross
they trudge through feet deep mud this
is just the first of many obstacles
they'll face in the coming days and it
will only get harder
it's not oncoming for groups of families
to make this incredible journey
in different groups as it were so wife
or husband might separate and bring the
kids afterwards then grandparents Etc
depending how it goes but
this
this Trail used to be considered
virtually impossible now as you can see
there's people making
this journey every single day
Carlos Chinchin Comforts his little boy
Carlito by singing
[Music]
his wife and their second child have
already made the crossing and are in the
United States
they want to find them but they have
absolutely no idea where they are
very American house
and are you worried about taking this
little one such a long way
a few hours in we meet Michael again
it's hard he says that he has Faith he
knows the U.S border is closed to
Venezuelans now but this family is
determined
and there's going to be worse ahead I
think it is
even if they get through the Gap to
Panama there are six more borders to
cross but they just keep going it's a
huge movement of people which is only
expected to increase
it's hard to see how it will be stopped
Stuart Ramsey Sky News nadarian Gap